[Music]
hydrogenation i'm greg halfa I don't
think we're striking the right tone for
the video we're gonna watch a video that
I'm hoping I make it on this list 5
creepiest youtubers moments caught on
video boy I hope these are fun creepy
and not genuinely creepy you can I can
make you have a creepy moment okay
alright this is from top 5 unknowns a
great YouTube channel more of you guys
should be subscribing then bollock at
Alvarado on the socials of the media's
people I'm telling you worth your time
links in the description box and thanks
Kat for these shirts keep it her sure -
yeah more than happy to you know does
stress god is real so excited to find
out what happens - what's going on you
guys my name is ty knots and welcome to
top 5 unknowns 5 most disturbing moments
caught my youtubers no 5 this first clip
comes from a youtuber named spunk not a
casual vlog in which a dog could be seen
in the background yes he was quite short
with him simply asking users to follow
him on Google+ so he can become verified
no just keep your eye on the doll hey
YouTube spunk flunky so today I wanted
to ask you all a huge favor and if you
guys could help me out that would be
great and that favor is to help me get
verified on Google+ slash YouTube and to
do that I need 1,000 followers on
Google+ I only have about 123 right now
so if you could just click the link down
below in the description I'll take you
to my Google+ page ok anything um
click Add to circles and then just click
following that'd be awesome
it only take like a few seconds and now
get me to 1000 followers
you know what five days and then I'll
finally have a little check mark by my
name and that would make me really happy
so if you guys could do that that'd be
really really awesome and before I end
this video I would like to give a shout
out to Kings cypher productions
if you want to go check them out links
to his channel is down below so thanks
for watching
d so what happened until his hand moved
we got a player back later okay youtuber
guala Q's coming from his front door
yeah every time superb there he says
that the knocking has been going on for
a few days and as we Gunz you appear all
throughout his house your front door is
in his home Oh interesting
hey everyone so I just woke up from a
nap and okay I heard knocking in the
front door that's what woke me up
I checked the front door no one was
there and all of a sudden I heard this
same knocking that back door over there
I checked no one was there and it's been
happening for like the last two days now
and I don't know what it is I've been
hearing weird noises I keep thinking
it's like the airplane or like a car
outside but I'm starting to think it's
like something
I don't know if you read that like
I was like a chairs you think is real no
I don't have nipple chills at the same
time though I do not share than I do not
share the nipple chills no he's faking
this
so apparently on the previous owners
there's like something tragic that
happened to that oh god is so fake I
don't know
rebounded but you've got like a seven
year old brother who's like hiding it it
seems so not real I just don't believe
him I need to see it like on camera like
the thing opening with no one there okay
and alien has to pop out if he gets
murdered on camera then oh oh my gosh
don't go in I can't I can't I can't do
this is not I didn't do this with
someone I obviously needed to do that
with someone I can't do that right now
that's freaking scary I believe in him
there okay how about this I'm just gonna
leave the camera here I'm gonna go
outside take like a take a quick walk
you'll see nothing happens how do we
know you're walking I just go around
that's knock you
[Laughter]
what
okay but we don't see like the other
side yeah in a lot of ways so doing it
better yeah massive youtuber Jo Ellen
who's filming a video inside ever to
asylum when he begins to hear all sorts
of unexplainable noises and even has
something thrown at him at one point all
throughout the video just enables us to
revolution inside shadows though the
clip you're about to see is certainly
the strangest have a lot 103 you can't
have a friend just like in another room
yeah mister channel his arm skipping
arms
[Music]
so who's up in the bank top place is
fine
imagine if it isn't even more anything
right now because we're just coming out
hello oh my god I could never just
wandering around a building like there's
gonna be a serial killer like an actual
murder exploring old mine case well I
know mine no it's hardware and he
stumbles across a chain that if used to
be waving back and forth there's a
youtube channel for everything he
believes there's some sort of
supernatural presence in the cave and
refuses to return to film any sort of
follow up videos check it out and
looking down the tunnel here
oh I don't want cheese swing back there
don't know you can see that the video or
not negative in other world well like
people do die and oh look the rut more
of them are swinging now it can be like
rats their imaginations mine definitely
has a very spooky vibe to it
so I'm gonna head back out the other
stuff that's here this is just to when
to money that's what she says like money
partner comes from Jake Paul who visits
an abandoned building in order to use a
Ouija board to contact any possible
spirits I'm sorry
that's so rude
I didn't see I don't see [ __ ] oh it
could just be a light reflection though
good or not yeah dude my hands are
barely touching I could lift them up
right now they killed some water oh my
god no joke no joke dude I'm out dude I
have no skills brother's never been
scared making a video you know I have
the chills dude we're all right here
I have the chills it's all gonna be here
imagination you all can leave you know
you don't have to stay with it brah but
dude bro
what what is it what are they circling
look that kinda like a shirt oh [ __ ]
security guards
thank you guys so much for watching
maybe he's just broken ender because
your place I kind of feel like that a
lot of the time because a lot of this
was let me just make you look a little
bit I kind of feel like a lot of times
this [ __ ] just plays into your
imagination when you're by yourself you
know like your mind just starts to
imagine stuff when you're isolated you
just think of stuff it could be you just
believe it cuz I feel like most of these
videos like [ __ ] but what I'm
watching them in the moment I am going
oh my god what is it what is it what is
it you know but then when in retrospect
like yeah it's my mind [ __ ] with me
but I got a playback the first one this
one was the creepiest one in my opinion
all right let's let's find out if you're
telling me the truth watch the hand had
already moved
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
no it's legit moving yeah football for
some like [ __ ] aftereffect [ __ ] right
viral like a year ago it was like a
school and lay UK somewhere and then
like the lockers were opening in Chanel
yeah and like oh we captured a real-life
haunting on camera and then someone who
was just like oh no you can tell it's
after-effects I mean the more subtle the
easier would be to do that but then it's
also like classy have a daughter he's
he's messing with us he wants followers
what is he doing he's telling us to
follow him
yeah we're gonna re-watch this video he
said that video goes viral just play it
just play it I hope weren't included in
your next list pick up all my pens guava
juice I gotta admit this guy had me kind
of going back and forth this is fake
this is it's it's like it was his acting
that I just wasn't really buying but
then there was like a couple of moments
he's going up the Attic and then he
stops whoo [ __ ] that like a real
reaction you were having right there but
then you know even that later bit when
he's uh you know thing with a sliding
door a too much you gotta go with subtle
doll hand perfect this is ridiculous and
there could literally be someone who is
checking the frame cuz it because it has
the thing where it says cut to two
minutes later and there's it gives me
someone on the frames opening and
closing it you know you can even do it
with like a broom handle just to do it
like towards the bottom because he
there's a couch that is blocking the
bottom foot of that
door so he could be like on the floor
back there like moving that with some
kind of exactly it could if it was a
wide shot guava if you're watching him
trying to give you a bike who's a wide
shot with no couch in there and then you
pulled it up maybe what you might have
had me going for a second but say you're
gonna go on a walk for a few minutes
leave the camera on if you had like a
livestream where you're like actually
out walking now we might have an angle
okay there it is I don't see anything
are they a [ __ ] fraud I mean it's not
even moving in the TV yeah that might be
some kind of special
maybe they edited it out you could just
replace whatever's in the image yeah you
can replace whatever's in the TV frame
because there's nothing's even moving in
the TV or it could be just be reflecting
the other side of this door no that
wouldn't makes sense because you got
this you got this corner of the couch
here is that reflecting yeah it's
reflecting that's right yeah so we
should be able to see the door opening
it's fake there's nothing wrong myth
busted right there this one too easy
yeah okay I mean that this is creepy
this was a found footage movie I would
be terrified knowing that it's youtubers
trying to sell us on something real
happening obviously I would so be a part
of that like if you were like hey let's
go make a haunting I would be that girl
behind the wall being left yeah or
whatever silence I don't think she was
making cat noises it didn't have any
emotion to the acting this girl was just
like okay okay but the cave stuff hey
what's this cave guys Channel she's kind
of like spooky caves and go look at the
weird spooky [ __ ] here I feel negative
energy or is this a what
wrench from 1952 and if you see it's
from Sears I can replace that's what I
thought actually thought it was kind of
like one of those oh wow there's a
channel for mind games whatever but then
he had all these like text of like I
feel negative energy and all these
things that his channel just like
exploring spooky-looking caves that is
pretty creepy though I mean the chains
moving that doesn't look like someone is
altering that yeah but I feel like my
myth-busting years of professionalism
yes of course
oh I just don't like believe I want to
believe in ghosts I tear it all apart
because if I am gonna believe it I'm
gonna believe it I could see this being
some kind of magnetic field issue
something with the minerals and the
rocks that's where you're the
professional science it's science
I've got a negative energy what no
that's magnets magnets probably which
are also have some kind of energy if you
guys got to this part in the video once
you comment and attacked cats
perspective magnets great you could good
man spleen some say yeah I genuinely
invite you to explain what the brain is
too tiny to understand what demons are
actually up I never believe anything the
husband reports I loved Ouija board
stories though they're the best they're
great stories
did you hear that how's my fridge if I
want to believe something I won't
believe what was all [ __ ] I don't
believe this was supposed to be the
creepiest one of all of them yeah I mean
by the time I got to this one I thought
it was all diluted down and this is like
the least creepy okay what they're
seeing here that looks I don't know it
looks like it's it's a it's a light
reflection to me I guess how one
person's mind can perceive that is to be
you know a person moving out of yes so
it's supposed to be that like yeah yeah
right here
you know like that could also be the
person who called security I don't think
that I thought there was a shadow let me
okay what play go back I want to see so
it's supposed to be that bump thing yeah
right here hmm see how I like then
leaves frame see it looks like a sleeve
of someone so a that's either the person
who called security on you guys or B
it's the light because as the shadow
begins to come over here more yeah it
could be a curtain because there's all
kinds of weird like peeling yeah I I
don't I just don't think that's an
actual person that's like really but
that's your mind playing tricks on you
man it's not it dude dude bro
it's the Wii yeah exactly
all these guys need to cut back a little
bit is what I'm thinking alright guys
well do you think this was real okay
could you not give it away so leave a
comment about anything down below
anything anything at all you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation hey click
that notification about while you're at
it do it Kat Alvarado is on Facebook
follow her page Twitter and Instagram go
check her out over there look at
Alvarado yep it's well worth it but you
just gotta be talking to then oh my god
I mean if we can have it like just come
way high up this videos done where
juvenile